[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz tolles
grillrezepte und zwar stammt das rezept
von der mafia von meiner besten freundin
und ihr papa da ist aus dem iran der
lodge der papa roach hallo papa ich
grüße dich ganz lieb und heute mache ich
dein rezept und zwar den sachfragen zu
thronen hohen am spieß am spieß also auf
dem grill und es macht ja immer wenn wir
dort grillen und jetzt habe ich mir
gedacht mach' ich dieses geniale rezept
einmal für euch und zwar sind das
zitronen safran hähnchenspieße und dazu
kommen grill tomaten
die werden dann verdrückt wie so eine
art warmer salat und ich mache heute
dazu noch ein bisschen naturreis ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
spieße nämlich ein kilo hähnchenbrust
zwei zitronen ein gramm safran 40 km
olivenöl etwas salz und pfeffer und eine
knoblauchzehe jetzt stelle ich zuerst
die marinade für das hin und her
dafür nehme ich mir eine schale und die
zitronen die sind alle um behandelt das
heißt ich kann die schale einfach mit
verzehren
das steht auch in meist direkt am
schildchen mit dran und ich werde jetzt
nicht treiben sondern einfach abstellen
mit einem sparschäler und da achte ich
darauf dass ich wirklich nur den gelben
teil erwischen und nicht ihn weißen teil
der schmeckt nämlich bitter
da dem ich jetzt nur die hälfte davon
weil es einfach ansonsten zu intensiv
wird und beim und bei der anderen
zitrone nämlich auch die schale ab
verkleiden was ihr in free sie ein so
habe ich immer zitronenschale auf vorrat
kann man übrigens auch richtig toll
zitronen zucker herstellen
ich hätte selbst zum beispiel eine
ziemlich von beiden zitronensaft
er war mit dazu pressen
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt nur den saft von drei
halben zu drohnen weil ich einfach schon
etwas mehr als 75 milliliter habe und
ich kaufte wirklich immer unbehandelter
zitronen die sind zwar ein bisschen
teurer aber wenn ihr überlegt ihr
verwendet die schale komplett dann dem
zitronensaft und dann nehme ich den rest
nehmen hier die kerne raus und steckst
noch als spülmaschinen der in die
spülmaschine
dann habt ihr wirklich alles ausgenutzt
und dann ist die zitrone gar nicht mehr
so teuer
so könnt ihr einfach viel viel mehr
damit anfangen hier gebe ich jetzt noch
das olivenöl dazu dann salz und pfeffer
die knoblauchzehe die hacke ich jetzt in
feine scheiben
die kommt dann auch dazu und wenn ihr
möchtet dann gerne noch safran
ich habe jetzt hier gemahlin safran das
sorgt einfach für eine schöne intensive
farbe
und dann schön früher ihr könnt im
prinzip auch kurkuma nehmen wenn ihr das
gerne mit es gibt auch eine richtig
schöne gelbe farbe sieht man auch schon
richtig schön die farbe ich habe jetzt
übrigens nur ein viertel gramm gebraucht
gemalt und jetzt schneide ich das
hähnchenfleisch einfach in etwa 3 x 3 cm
große würfel
beim arbeiten mit geflügel nur immer
darauf achten dass das werkzeug was ich
hier dann benutzt danach wirklich sofort
und gründlich reinigt also danach nicht
noch den salat drauf schneiden sondern
wirklich gründlich waschen damit einfach
keine salmonellen sich verbreiten
falls welche vorhanden wären jetzt
können wir im prinzip die marinade mit
dem hähnchen vermischen entweder schön
massieren und dann im kühlschrank
gelagert so zwei bis drei stunden ziehen
lassen
ich war es jetzt allerdings anders ich
nehme jetzt die wako schublade und werde
jetzt hier im vakuumbeutel das hähnchen
einfüllen die marinade einfüllen und
dann verkürzt sich sozusagen die
mariniert seien durch die warmen
schublade entsteht nämlich schon unter
druck die luft wird rausgezogen und das
fleisch wird sofort mit der marinade
mariniert als das aroma trinkt sofort
rein und vor allem könnt ihr sodann das
hähnchen vorbereiten
dann habt ihr alles in einem beutel
verschlossen den beutel könnt ihr auch
wieder verwenden indem er oben einfach
die naht weg schneidet der wir werden
zwar kleiner mit der zeit aber können
denn wirklich so oft gebrauchen wie eben
was reinpasst und man kann es zumindest
auch für den nächsten tag vorbereiten
und das hähnchen so etwas länger haltbar
machen
ich habs jetzt oben einfach umgeschlagen
damit oben daran sauber bleibt
da kommt jetzt das hinten rein man muss
natürlich trotzdem immer sauber und
hygienisch arbeiten
ich mache das alles in einem beutel aber
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch zwei kleine
beutel nehmen eine portion heute eine
prozent für morgen und so wirklich auch
ganz viel arbeit sparen und beim bakom
ihren muss man nur darauf achten dass
man wirklich nicht zu viele gewürze
nimmt weil sich das auch immer sehr
intensiviert
ich habe jetzt also das aroma hier an
den akku mir schublade angepasst das
heißt wenn jetzt ohne vakuum schublade
arbeitet und ohne vakuum ihr gerät könnt
ihr gerne auch noch eine knoblauchzehe
dazugeben und etwas mit drohnen schale
zum beispiel so wie ihr das gerne habt
murat max immer nicht ganz so zitronig
aber das ist das rezept von der mafia
ein persisches rezept
ich glaube wenn es zitronen safran
hähnchen heißt es auch zu schmecken
ich liebe zitrone schon mal ziemlich gut
aus wie gesagt entweder jetzt in den
kühlschrank stellen und drei stunden
marinieren gerne auch über nacht oder
einfach in der schublade zu speisen und
standen ist es wirklich gleich mariniert
[Musik]
jetzt ist das hähnchen perfekt
vakuumiert ich kann jetzt in den
kühlschrank stellen wie es sich eben
später grille und kann ihn da
zwischenzeit schon mal den tomaten salat
zubereiten
für die grill tomaten verwende ich 800
gramm cocktailtomaten eine unbehandelte
zitrone eine knoblauchzehe seltsamen
cayennepfeffer schwarzer pfeffer und
salz sowie cad hat ein handy und pc die
tomaten braucht es wirklich gehe jetzt
grillspieße gilt später diesen oben weil
man mal in der küche okay und ich kann
so lange die marinade machen wird den
grill salat und zwar nehme ich jetzt die
knoblauchzehe die kontinente nehmen die
jetzt den mörser oder bereit gemahlene
gewürze wurde sagen oder nehmt einfach
hier auch so eine gewürzmühle da kommen
die koriander samen dazu der pfeffer
cayennepfeffer ob sie habe ich koriander
gesagt es waren zusammen
so nehme ich jetzt die zitrone und die
hälfte der zitrone werde ich jetzt viele
tiere da kommen die filets nämlich auch
mit rein und die andere hälfte david
wird der zitronensaft ausgepresst also
ich jetzt erstmal auch zitronensaft so
ich bin da wer bin ich wer wenig mit den
scherenhänden
natürlich bringt das wirtschaftsamt
machen mich abstechen
ich wollte normale grillspieße für die
tomaten patent dann habe ich die falsche
tomate oder die falsche spiel sind nicht
scharf nein es ist wie so ein schwert
das sind alte osmanische grillspieße und
zwar ein papa kommt übrigens im
türkischen gemüse macht ja es geht aber
dann nur mit türkischer große tomate
weil wir soll ich ihnen ganz ehrlich die
cocktailtomaten auf spies war das falsch
ich kann vielleicht anderer spitze
[Musik]
damit kann es aber machen
mach doch mal ab aber für uns wollt ihr
dass der murat maradona macht für uns
dass kritische doch hier ja ja kaum
holte andere spießig macht solange das
dressing vergessen hat beim dressing das
öl
da kommt noch öl rein ich mache noch ein
bisschen olivenöl rein so olivenöl dazu
hatte sie rot gehen weiter so vielen
fehlern
ich komme nur ein paar mehr und dann
klappt's ja ok und jetzt werde ich
einfach die gewürze zerkleinern
wie gesagt kurz in der gewürzmühle
jetzt noch das salz dazu und die übrige
zitrone
da nehme ich jetzt die schale weg ich
habs jetzt ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt
dumm angestellt
ich habe zuerst filetieren sollen und
dann den rest auspressen
aber na ja es geht auch so ich nehme mir
kurz die schale runter da nehme ich ein
bisschen nämlich was rein und jetzt
stehe ich hier den weißen teil weg jetzt
hier die filets und die kommen dann mit
hier rein und die gebe ich jetzt erst
dazu damit sie eben nicht zerkleinert
werden wo noch schön stück ich bleiben
nur mal hätte jetzt aber auch die ganze
zitrone einfach filetieren können und
den rest einfach aus preston und hier
lege ich jetzt noch zwei zitronenschale
dazu damit so einfach ein bisschen
ziehen und jetzt habe ich erst mal alle
bestandteile vorbereitet also die
tomaten werde ich gleich noch auf
spießen
die marinade kann ich so lange kühl
stellen das hähnchen steht kühl und ich
werde dazu noch reich verlieren und
nehmen da jetzt ein rad natur einst dem
könnt ihr entweder im topf zu bereiten
also mit wasser und da steht auch immer
auf der verpackung darauf wie viel
wasser pro reis drauf muss also pro
tasse reist ich werde den reis ist
allerdings im dampfgarer zu bereiten
weil er so im dampf daran ist lebt nicht
anbrennt und die perfekte konsistenz
bekommt das kaninchen rausnehmen und auf
spießen
ich habe jetzt nur noch wenige
metallspitze und noch ein paar holzspieß
jetzt einfach schön aufspießen nicht zu
eng
damit es hähnchen wirklich auch
gleichmäßig durchgang kann
ich habe dies schon lange
[Musik]
und so spielt sich jetzt einmal die
griechen auf die spitze auf und dann die
tomaten
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles vorbereitet und das geht
an die zubereitung ich werde jetzt
zuerst den reis jahren ich hab ich jetzt
naturreis wo die doppelte menge wasser
die gebe ich jetzt hier eine prise salz
habe ich noch mit dabei und jetzt kommt
das ganze in den dampfgarer war einlegen
und dann 35 minuten bei 100 grad dämpfen
oder eben im kochtopf zu bereiten
ich bin jetzt hier drinnen weil wir
draußen noch keinen grill haben jetzt
zuerst die tomaten und betreute sie mit
bisschen olivenöl und wie gesagt das
können wir gerne auch draußen beim gang
zubereiten und auf dem grill
ich werde jetzt zuerst grillen damit ich
den salat fertigstellen kann und danach
dann das hähnchen die tomaten grill ich
jetzt so lange bis er in schönwald sind
also aus und runzlig und dann kommen sie
gleich eine große schale zum zu drücken
[Musik]
wenn die tomaten dann weit sind dann
einfach unternehmen
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt hin und grill das
auch schön
[Musik]
hier kann ich jetzt die tomaten 1 fr 10
können wir dann wirklich beim grillen
direkt am tisch machen weil er sowieso
alles andere vorbereitet ist
[Musik]
jetzt hier das dressing darüber geben
und da passen die senfkörner echt gut
dazu und jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
zerstampfen
[Musik]
das rad ist fertig die linien sind
gleich fertig und der reise auch
gleichzeitig also kann ich schon mal
jemanden holen zum probieren
der reis fertig hähnchen des wertes der
salat ist fertig und der murat steht in
den startlöchern
murat der reis wird immer perfekt aus
dem dampfgarer mega oder wie soll ich
sagen
die iranische küche ist eine absolut
geniale abgang ermöglichen
es liegt einfach wie sie ihren reis
zubereiten tja und vor allem die gewürze
die sie verwenden richtig gehen ja als
wenn die iraner und afghanen er habe
dort mein essen etwas ganz ganz
besonderes um eine ganz ganz andere
geschmacksrichtungen und wenn ihr die
möglichkeit habt heiratet einen dann
habt ihr rezept seite gerichte jeden tag
lösen sollten
der karton für seine frau weil ich jetzt
ja der hat uns mal die geniale lammkeule
zubereitet hatte murat ist futsch das
rezept papa oder opa durch wie die heime
sagt da war es noch ein ganz kleines
leben ich weiß was du sagst du mal dass
der markt schon reiste mag ich keine
warmen ort wo ich gerade sondern auch
gemacht und mir lage ist kurzzeitig sah
gesagt aber lieber nicht aber ich weiß
dass das so nicht manchmal mag ich es
kommt auf die tagesform an feuerwehrmann
beispiel sagen damit ist das kann ja
okay meint tomatensoße magst du ja auch
ich glaube es nicht nur wenn es dann
stück ist ja so freudig muskelprobleme
mal ich finde es genial die persische
küche allgemein die hat auch diesen
diesen luft rein ist kein studium gut
ich habe jetzt naturreis genommen bei
natur ist einfach super gesund ist da
werden erwägt die vitamine und
nährstoffe aus der schale in die in den
reis reingepresst also weißen reis essen
wir eigentlich selten oder kaum wirklich
immer naturreis unsere dampfbad perfekt
kohlenwäsche reist ja und trotzdem und
aber auch nicht so hart und nicht so wie
wir denken reist kann man die falsch
machen glaubt man reist kann man richtig
bestimmt dieses fleisch die farbe allein
überall schön sauer
hast du eine zitrone hier hat man soll
nicht drin jetzt meine frage schnell
warst du benutzt maria 3 bei hähnchen
natürlich ganz wichtig immer durch
genehme durch aber trotzdem noch zahlen
und nicht trocken war und auch bei
hinten spielen kann nicht viel falsch
machen
wir müssen zu lange darauf lässt wenn es
richtig hart ist dann ja ja wieder
richtig das stammt wenn es ruhig damit
der tag gelaufen muss ich dann gibt es
gebe mir große flügel ist gut gestartet
tomaten oder soll ich die ersten stromer
okay aber ich wusste dass ich wusste
eben als der wäre habe ich nichts aber
also dann kriegt schon noch ein bisschen
mehr tomatensaft ich es die tomaten und
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
vom opa watch dann schaut gerne auch
cell.de vorbei ich hoffe es ist genau so
geworden wie erste mal macht jedoch und
willi zum iran wie immer zu machen
geniales essen wirklich toll also viel
spaß beim grill und bis zum nächsten mal
müssen wir noch der oper mottola vermute
ja sonst schon mal zu bereiten und ihn
bringen
[Musik]